ron please
no no way come on ron i've been a loyal
foot soldier give me my shot
let me have lot 48
is that a travel pillow around your neck
ron
i don't know how to explain this to you
when you've been down in the pit have
you been in the pit
no i haven't gotten down there yet well
i have when you fell in when i visited
the bottom of the pit on a fact-finding
mission
and when you're down there you get some
perspective about
what it all means
let me tell you something ron
what it means is
i want this subcommittee
i've been quite open about this around
the office i don't want this parks
department to build any parks because i
don't believe in government i think that
all government
is a waste of taxpayer money
my dream is to have the park system
privatized and run entirely for profit
by corporations
like chuck e cheese
they have an impeccable business model i
would rather work for chuck e cheese
ron swanson it is my pleasure to inform
you that you are a finalist for the job
of assistant city manager chris i feel i
should remind you that i do not believe
that the position or the entire
government should exist that said you'd
be a fool not to pick me i will walk
deeper into the belly of the beast if it
means i'm able to further limit reckless
government spending i mean i have so
many ideas
some are simple like take down traffic
lights and eliminate the post office the
bigger ones will be tougher like
bring all of this crumbling to the
ground
so after all that it's really not that
bad
you're gonna get a letter in your file
ron i just wanted to say thank you don't
worry about it
no i didn't i didn't do it for leslie i
did it because i hate bureaucracy my
idea of a perfect government is
one guy who sits in a small room at a
desk and the only thing he's allowed to
decide is who to nuke
the man is chosen based on some kind of
iq test
and maybe also a physical tournament
like a decathlon
and women
are brought to him maybe
when he desires them
although candy is our bread and butter
we also care about the health of our
customers and that's why we'll be
debuting our new
healthy energy bar
nutrients
take a look
hi i'm nick newport jr
ceo of sweden's
and i'd like to introduce to you our new
line of energy bars nutrients
we start with 100 all natural corn then
we add just a little bit of sweetums
corn syrup a little drop of sunshine and
some other stuff and since they're from
sweetums you know your kids are going to
work oh that family looks so healthy
look at them they're all wearing vests
dakota dinner
sorry too lace we don't make nutrients
for dogs
yet
shoelace nutri yums where nutritious
meats tasty by sweden
if
i could not be happier about this i
think the entire government should be
privatized
chuck e cheese could run the parks
everything operated by tokens
drop in a token go on the swing set drop
in another token take a walk
drop in a token look at a duck
nutrium's energy bars are just
absolutely loaded with high fructose
corn syrup and fatty oils and any way
you slice it they're just extremely
unhealthy for you
leslie needs to butt out the whole point
of this country is if you want to eat
garbage balloon up to 600 pounds and i
have a heart attack at 43 you can you
are free to do so
to me that's beautiful i enjoy
government functions like i enjoy
getting kicked in the nuggets with a
steel toe boot
but this hotel always serves
bacon-wrapped shrimp
that's my number one favorite food
wrapped around my number three favorite
food i'd go to a banquet and honor those
somali pirates if they serve
bacon-wrapped shrimp excuse me
hey table twelve can i get a what what
wow
thank you
i mean ann you look stunning but leslie
wow i was going for a while you got it
i was told it was black tie i like your
hairdo leslie thank you ron it's just
like my brothers he's an officer in the
air force
bacon-wrapped shrimp oh thanks i'm okay
i was an offer
hey hey am i interrupting something
important impossible i work for the
government i just picked up the girls
thought we stopped by or the girls
yes they are hello girls
diane and i have been seeing a lot of
each other recently she is a sharp
confident strong woman her children are
loud
[Applause]
this is fun easy girls we'll be careful
miss lewis
i'm sorry
we just wanted to invite you to come
trick-or-treating tonight i think i'm a
little old can we go wrong please
please oh you can come sure we have to
go buy seven or else good can you'll be
gone
sounds perfect
what the hell just happened hey bro
listen i was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of b25
mitchell panchito aircraft for me don't
sass me and i went to this website and
this ad popped up that said hey ron
swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell
like how do they know who you are
yeah
okay um there are these things called
cookies where like if you go to a site
and buy something it'll remember you and
then create ads for other stuff you
might want to buy so it learns
information about me
seems like an invasion of privacy dude
if you think that's bad go to google
earth and type in your address
with current and projected deficits
we need to cut expenditures by 32 let's
make it an even 40. oh that's not
necessary slash it slash [ __ ] i am an
official member of a task force
dedicated to slashing the city budget
just saying that gave me a semi
right off the bat we sell city hall
let somebody turn it into a large gas
station or a tj maxx ron that is a very
creative idea but we don't want to sell
any of our major assets because we don't
want to lose out on any future revenue
streams i hear that don't worry i have
tons more ideas okay uh
so sorry
new ringtone don't cut anything without
me
can i help you
hi my class is here on a field trip and
i'm supposed to interview someone for a
school project
okay
you can wait at that table and someone
will be here sometime
but aren't you here now
no
my report's due tomorrow what's it on
why government matters
really
it's never too early to learn that the
government is a greedy piglet that
suckles on a taxpayer's teat until they
have sore chapped nipples
i'm gonna need a different metaphor to
give this nine-year-old
what's your name ma'am lauren burkus
lauren
my name is ron swanson and i'm gonna
tell you everything you need to know
about the miserable screwed up world of
local government
you mustered in your mustache
don't sass me berkus
let's get started this is your lunch
now you should be able to do whatever
you want to with this right
if you want to eat all of it great if
you want to throw it away in the garbage
that's your prerogative but here i come
the government
and i get to take 40 of your lunch
and that lauren is how taxes work
but that's not fair you're learning
uh-oh
capital gains tax
and that lauren is how fdr ruined this
country lauren going now ready to head
back well i guess it's time for you to
head home
i've really enjoyed talking with you
you are and this is not a joke
much smarter than most of the people who
work in this building i like talking
with you too mr swanson
wrong
wow hang on hang on i have something for
you
this
is a claymore landmine
use that to protect your property
thanks ron
you got it
3-1-1 well diane for potholes you want
to speak with public works
i understand you've tried them four
times government is inefficient and
should be dissolved please hold while i
transfer you
you